but um so
you guys do not know um for those new here i am not a singer
i'm a terrible singer uh this is like a little warning a
little disclaimer for those of you who don't want to you
know have their ears bleed blight out uh i am not very good
at singing but this year my resolution i'm starting singing
lessons this year let's go
It's jazz time, guys.
It's time to jazz.
Look for the bare necessities, the simple bare necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strife.
I mean the bare necessities, old Mother Nature's recipes
that bring the bare necessities of life.
I wonder wherever I roam I couldn't be fonder of my big home
the bees are buzzing in the trees to make some honey just
for me then you look under the rocks and plants and take a
glance at a fancy ants then maybe try a few the
bare necessities of life will come to you.
They'll come to you.
Look for the bare necessities, the simple bare necessities.
Forget about your worries and your strides.
I mean the bare necessities.
That's why a bear can rest at ease with just the bare
necessities of life.
Now when you pick a paw-paw, or a prickly pear, and you
prick a raw paw, well next time beware.
Don't pick the prickly pear by the paw when you pick a pear
try to use the claw.
But you don't need to use the claw when you pick a pair of
the big paw-paw.
Have I given you a clue?
I don't even know what the fuck I'm seeing!
They'll come to you.
Yo!
It's jazz!
Boo!
Jazz solo!
Ba-da-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Ba-da-ba-ba.
Oh shit!
Maracas time!
Oh!
Maracas!
I'm jazzing!
Oh, I'm jazzing!
Oh, man.
This is really living.
So, just try and relax.
Yeah.
Cool it.
Fall apart in my backyard.
Because let me tell you something, little britches.
If you act like that bees act, uh-uh.
You're working too hard.
spend your time looking around for something you want that
can be found when you find out you can live about and go
along not thinking about it and tell you something true the
bare necessities of life will come to you
look for the bare necessities the simple life bare
necessities for about your worries and your strife.
I mean the bare necessities.
That's why a bear can rest at ease.
But just the bare necessities of life.
With just the bare necessities of life.
Woo!
Jazz!
And that's how you jazz, guys.
That's how you fucking jazz.
Alright, that's why I told you guys.
I'm very bad at singing.
That is, this is the first song, the first song of the year.
And we're not going to have a song until I get better at
singing.
Thank you, everyone.
We're listening.